we start this hour with breaking news as
police investigate a homicide in the
central valley
yeah it happened this afternoon at a car
wash near charleston and lindell that's
where we find
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
who has the latest for us here at five
o'clock
yes that's correct okay so this is what
we know so far there was just a media
briefing where lieutenant spencer gave
more details
to the situation a man in his early 40s
was shot multiple time at the go car
wash right off of
west charleston boulevard take a look at
the video that we shot earlier where you
can see more of the extent of the scene
he was here vacuuming his car with his
wife the man was rushed to the hospital
and later pronounced dead his wife is
said to be okay
the suspect who is currently on the run
is believed to know the victim but of
course we will keep you updated
throughout the night with more details
once again a hispanic male in his early
40's was shot multiple times
while vacuuming his car at the go car
wash right here
off of west charleston boulevard